la maladie ne rencontrera pas une grande résistance
et se propagera de personne en personne
et en peu de temps sera disséminée dans toute la communauté.
Après un certain temps,
la plupart de la population sera malade
C'est ce qui se passait quand il n'y avait pas de vaccins.
Maintenant, imaginez le cas inverse.
Nous sommes dans une ville
où plus de 90% de la population
est immunisée contre la rougeole, ce qui signifie
qu'ils ont eu la maladie, ont survécu et ont développé des défenses naturelles,
ou qu'ils ont reçu un vaccin anti-rougeole.
Et un jour,
une personne atteinte de rougeole apparait dans la ville,
la maladie va rencontrer beaucoup plus de résistance
et ne sera pas transmise autant d’une personne à l’autre.
La propagation reste alors sous contrôle
et l’épidémie de rougeole ne se déclare pas.
Je voudrais que vous fassiez attention à quelque chose
Les personnes vaccinées
ne protègent pas qu'elles-mêmes.
Mais, en bloquant la dissémination de la maladie
dans la société,
elles protègent indirectement les autres personnes de la société
qui ne sont pas vaccinées.
Elles créent une sorte de bouclier
qui empêche leur mise en contact avec la maladie,
ces personnes demeurent protégées.
Cette protection indirecte
que reçoivent les personnes non vaccinées dans la communauté
en étant tout simplement entourées de gens protégés
s'appelle l’immunisation collective.
Une grande proportion de la population
dépend presque exclusivement de cette immunité
afin d’être protégée contre les maladies.
Ces personnes non vaccinées ne sont pas hypotétiques
dans une représentation graphique.
Ces personnes sont nos nièces et neveux, nos enfants,
qui pourraient être trop jeunes pour recevoir leurs premières injections.
Ce sont nos parents, nos proches,
nos connaissances,
qui pourraient être malades,
qui prennent un médicament fragilisant leurs systèmes immunitaires.
Ils existent aussi des gens allergiques à certains vaccins.
Ça peut être aussi chacun d'entre nous
si nous nous vaccinons,
mais que le vaccin n’a pas produit l’effet désiré.
Car tous les vaccins ne sont pas efficaces à 100%.
Tous ces gens dépendent presque exclusivement de l’immunité collective
pour être protégés contre les maladies.
Afin d’atteindre cet effet d'immunité collective,
il est nécessaire qu’un large pourcentage de la population soit vacciné.
Ce pourcentage est appelé le seuil.
Ce seuil dépend de plusieurs variables.
Il dépend des caractéristiques du germe,
et des caractéristiques de la réponse immunitaire que le vaccin génère.
Mais ils ont tous un point en commun.
Si le pourcentage de la population vaccinée dans une communauté
est en dessous du seuil,
la maladie commence à se propager plus librement
et il pourrait y avoir une épidémie.
Même les maladies déjà contrôlées risquent de réapparaitre.
Ce n’est pas qu’une théorie.
C'est déjà arrivé, et ça arrive encore.
En 1998, un chercheur britannique a publié un article
dans l’un des plus importants journaux médicaux,
qui disait que que le vaccin ROR, administré en prévention
de la rougeole, des oreillons et de la rubéole,
était associé à l’autisme.
Ça a eu un impact immédiat.
Les gens ont arrêté de se vacciner, et de vacciner leurs enfants.
Et qu’est ce qu'il s’est passé ?
Le nombre de personnes vaccinées,
dans de nombreuses communautés dans le monde, est tombé en dessous du seuil
et des épidémies de rougeole ont vu le jour dans de nombreux pays.
Aux États-Unis, en Europe,
de nombreuses personnes sont tombées malades.
Des personnes sont décédées.
Que s’est-il passé ?
Cet article a provoqué un énorme bruit dans la communauté médicale.
Des dizaines de chercheurs ont commencé à évaluer la crédibilité de l’article.
Non seulement personne n’a pu prouver une relation de causalité
entre le vaccin ROR et l’autisme au niveau de la population,
mais on a aussi trouvé que l’article avait des propos inexacts.
Plus encore, il était frauduleux.
Il était frauduleux.
En réalité, le journal a retiré l’article en 2010.
L’une des principales excuses pour ne pas se vacciner,
ce sont les effets indésirables.
Les vaccins, comme tout autre médicament, peuvent avoir des effets secondaires
qui sont bénins et transitoires pour la plupart.
Mais les bénéfices sont toujours plus importants que les complications.
Quand nous sommes malades, nous voulons guérir rapidement.
Beaucoup d'entre nous
prenons des antibiotiques, quand nous avons des infections,
des antihypertenseurs quand nous souffrons d’hypertension,
des médicaments pour les pathologies cardiaques.
Pourquoi ? Parce que nous sommes malades
et voulons guérir rapidement.
On ne se pose pas trop la question.
Pourquoi est-il si difficile de penser à prévenir les maladies,
en prenant soin de nous même quand nous sommes en bonne santé ?
Nous prenons beaucoup soin de nous une fois atteints d’une maladie,
ou dans une situation de danger imminent.
J’imagine que beaucoup parmi nous ici
se rappellent de la pandémie de grippe A
apparue en 2009 en Argentine et partout dans le monde.
Quand les premiers cas ont vu le jour,
nous, en Argentine, entamions l’hiver.
Nous ne savions absolument rien.
C'était une vaste pagaille.
Les gens mettaient des masques, courraient chercher du gel alcoolisé.
ils faisaient la queue dans les pharmacies pour se vacciner,
sans même savoir s’il s’agissait du bon vaccin
qui les protégerait contre le nouveau virus.
Nous ne savions absolument rien.
A l’époque, en plus de mon internat dans une fondation pour enfant,
je travaillais comme pédiatre à domicile pour une assurance médicale.
Je me rappelle avoir commencé mon service à 8h du matin.
Et à 8 h j’avais déjà une liste de 50 visites programmées.
C’était le chaos, les gens ne savaient pas quoi faire.
Je me souviens du type de patients que j’examinais.
Ils étaient un peu plus âgés que ceux que nous avions l’habitude de voir en hiver,
avec des fièvres plus persistantes,
et j’ai signalé ça à mon chef.
De son côté, il a entendu la même chose de la part d’un collègue,
à propos du grand nombre de femmes enceintes
et de jeunes adultes
hospitalisés en soins intensifs,
avec des profils cliniques sévères et critiques.
A ce moment-là, nous avons cherché à comprendre ce qu'il se passait.
Le lundi matin, nous avons commencé par prendre la voiture
et nous nous sommes rendus à l’hôpital de Buenos Aires,
qui servait d’hôpital de référence pour les cas de cette nouvelle grippe.
Nous sommes arrivés, l’hôpital était bondé.
Tout le personnel de santé était habillé comme à la NASA.
On avait tous des masques dans nos poches.
Moi, qui suis hypocondriaque, n’ai pas respiré pendant deux heures.
Mais on pouvait voir ce qui se passait.
Nous avons Immédiatement commencé à contacter les pédiatres
de six hôpitaux de la ville et de la province de Buenos Aires.
Notre but était de trouver
comment se comportait ce nouveau virus au contact de nos enfants
dans les plus brefs délais.
Un vrai marathon.
En moins de 3 mois,
on a pu voir quels effets ce nouveau virus H1N1 avait
sur les 251 enfants hospitalisés à cause de ce virus.
On pouvait quels enfants étaient plus sévèrement atteints :
les enfants de moins de 4 ans, essentiellement ceux de moins de 1 an,
les patients avec atteintes neurologiques,
et les jeunes enfants atteints de maladies pulmonaires chroniques.
Identifier ces groupes à risque était d’une grande importance
afin de les inclure comme groupes prioritaires
dans les recommandations pour la vaccination contre la grippe,
pas seulement ici en Argentine,
mais aussi dans les autres pays pas encore touchés par la pandémie.
Un an plus tard,
lorsqu’un vaccin contre le virus H1N1 est devenu disponible,
on a voulu ce qui s’était passé.
Après une énorme campagne de vaccination
qui visait à protéger les groupes à risque,
les hôpitaux avec 93 % de sujets à risque vaccinés
n’ont pas hospitalisé un seul patient
pour le virus H1N1.
(Applaudissements)
En 2009 : 251.
En 2010 : zéro.
La vaccination est un geste de responsabilité individuelle,
mais a un énorme impact collectif.
Si je me vaccine, non seulement je me protège,
mais je protège aussi les autres.
Sol souffrait de coqueluche.
Sol était très jeune,
et n’avait pas encore reçu son premier vaccin contre la coqueluche.
Je me demande toujours ce qu'il se serait passé
si tout le monde autour de Sol avait été vacciné.
(Applaudissements)